merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse est au ministre de l'action et
des comptes publics
ce n'est un secret pour personne les
deux grands perdants du quinquennat d'
emmanuel macron sont les retraités et
les familles et je veux parler
aujourd'hui de notre politique familiale
s'il ya bien un domaine dans lequel la
france excellait en comparaison avec ses
voisins européens c'est celui de la
natalité
et pourtant depuis plusieurs années
cette tendance est en train de
s'inverser
alors bien sûr il existe des réalités
sociologiques et des évolutions des
schémas de vie qui expliquent en partie
ce phénomène mais ces réalités
n'explique pas tout cette baisse
continue de la natalité est également à
mettre en lien avec la dégradation de
notre modèle de politique familiale
deux exemples à mme la ministre depuis
plusieurs mois bon nombre de familles
attendent le versement du complément de
libre choix de mode de garde
double peine puisque elles sont
également victimes de prélèvement de
cotisations indues deuxième exemple pour
la deuxième année consécutive
et à l'heure où le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale est
en discussion dans cet hémicycle les
prestations familiales seront sous
indexer ces événements et ses choix est
profondément sur l' équilibre financier
les familles alors je le dis avec
gravité
cette tendance est assez inédite depuis
la naissance de notre politique
familiale
ma question est simple et concise madame
la ministre le gouvernement entend t-il
délibérément affaiblir la politique
familiale française
[Applaudissements]